how's it going bros my name is Peter Pan
so today I wasn't gonna play a game with
Marzia but she's not available so might
yeah I'm sorry I didn't you were here
were you gonna let me motorboat you know
well you can't do that on YouTube
mindset my mom is watching please Italia
okay we're gonna play a game called push
me push you it's just come on it's
really cool I think you're really gonna
like this game in bed but in this game
it's kind of like cat dog and I'll be
the cat and you'll be the dog
cat dog is the cartoon from okay well
I'm gonna be the one on the left
okay so I'm I'm the ball game yeah no
you look in like it yeah you you look
really good
it's change for you no it looks the same
if you had a knee okay
my hair is it baking that one okay so I
am this guy on the lap yes there that is
creepy you're right okay pink team keep
the ball on here purple team keep the
ball in here okay you're the purple team
yeah yeah no mine you're saying no it's
my ball huh might set please myself I
have to win I am the man
oh oh you got a point can you stir OH
somebody said that mad Sam no give me my
ball back
why are you so jittery good at this game
for once oh come on
getting the suspiciously better today
[ __ ] you my said how does your voice
feel my said your eyes are watching you
yeah you're right oh I beat you at your
own game I said let me piss you yeah
please you're so beautiful
he's like the scene in the notebook when
you cry I've seen the net but you're
just distracting me for losing
no please please just get off [ __ ]
like what yeah yeah your turn to cry
[ __ ] cover yourself up what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you are they real I wrote you
every single day where ever wins this
one will be the dominant one tonight
okay I would like to be dominated by you
for once you do [ __ ] it's my ball we
talked about the balls Martin oh yeah
that is how this relationship that is
how you have my balls yeah that's how
it's done man yeah I'll get a new
girlfriend if you don't win this game
I'm sad I'm sad I'm sad come back to
play you letting me win yeah I'm sorry
cover yourself up woman
okay little eyes chance my chance are
you really that yes are you really are
you are you how do you win at this game
cuz I am so good at video games decided
yeah yeah bro yeah bro yeah what's that
yeah that way you're not my girlfriend
no no no not it Becky shame on you shame
on you do
did you like my makeup today uh yeah a
nice draw line toy
yeah no it's nice you might want to one
I did who went over all I did who won
your heart you did yeah no okay all
right we need to feed pool gasps thank
you for watching this video it's so much
leave it leave a like leave a like it
really helps out in the channel thank
you for subscribe you can check out my
channel by myself and as always